simone signoret michel foucault vous
revenez tout deux d'un voyage d'une
semaine en pologne
souvent les intellectuels parle des
choses sans aller les voir vous y êtes
allé alors simone signoret pourquoi moi
j'étais parce que j'ai profité d'un
convoi des médecins du monde qui est une
organisation dans laquelle mon mari et
moi on a milité le mot est bête mais
avec lesquels on avec laquelle on a
collaboré que ce soit pour le bateau
pour le vietnam ou pour l'avion pour le
salvador et j'ai été en pologne parce
que depuis le 13 décembre mon mari et
moi nous nous promenons dans paris est
sans danger et à new york est sans
danger avec cette petite broche sur le
côté j'ai pensé qu'il était la preuve de
la vérité qui est le signe de solidarité
j'ai trouvé que c'était très facile de
faire ça dans des villes où je vous
arrête pas et que c'est allez peut-être
le coup d'aller voir la base si vraiment
porter ça ça voulait dire quelque chose
alors juste je n'ai pas porté là bas je
vous le dis tout de suite j'ai pas eu ce
courage là personne ne l'a pas personne
ne peut la voir là bas
voilà la raison pour laquelle j'ai été
voir sur place alors justement une bonne
partie de l'opinion en france nourrit
une forme de dix ans de romantisme
parfois un peu confortable par rapport à
ce qui se passe en pologne
les gens que vous y avez rencontré ce
que vous avez eu le sentiment qu'il
s'agit de dissidents isolé où c'est
vraiment tout le pays
c'est en dissidence c'est absolument
tout le pays et tout le pays
ça ne veut pas dire non plus qu'ils ont
tous été des adhérents de solidarité ça
veut dire que le pays entier en tout cas
les gens qu'on a vu et les gens avec
lesquels on ne parle et ce aussi avec
lesquels on n'a pas parlé mais qu'on a
vu dans la rue dans les queues
moi qui ai vécu l'occupation j'ai jamais
vu ça pendant du patient d'asie à paris
dès que cet ordre devant des boutiques
dans lesquelles il ya rien
on a l'impression que dans ce pays où
tout est tragique où personne ne parle
plus parce qu'il ya des micros partout
on n'a pas rencontré une personne même
dans l'oeil des petits gars qu'on voit
passer en uniforme et dont on ne sait
plus s'ils sont des miliciens ou des
soldats parce que on a pris la
précaution de d'arranger leur uniforme
de telle sorte que personne ne s'y
retrouve on voit des choses dans les
yeux maintenant j'ai un exemple après je
les ferai parler michel foucault j'ai un
exemple que je veux donner parce que
pour moi il est extrêmement fraport il
touche ma profession et il m'a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup épaté j'ai entendu
parler de pays qui boycottait les
acteurs il ya même eu des pays où d'un
boycott est des acteurs qui avait pris
des positions politiques
la barre j'ai vu une chose que je
n'avais jamais vu ailleurs
j'ai vu des acteurs boycotter le travail
c'est à dire que les acteurs polonais
qui tous travaillent au théâtre enfin
fixe qu'il aurait garanti milk est très
petit et leur argent ils se le faisait
avec des émissions de télévision avec
des passages à la radio avec des
feuilletons avec les live collaborent
furent là que se ne met plus les pieds
devant une caméra de télévision et ne
met plus les pieds à la radio c'est un
courage absolument extraordinaire ça
n'est pas un syndicat qui l'implorent
leur en a donné l'ordre ça a été une
décision d'un individu qui forme
absolument la profession entière
des acteurs polonais et qui les deux ou
trois qui ont cru bon de passer à la
télévision et de dire comme il était
content parce que maintenant s'étaient
calmées c'était mieux qu'avant sont
boycottés par le public qui vient les
laisse les applaudit tellement qu'ils ne
peuvent pas travailler
voilà alors je peux dire de ma
profession et je suis j'ai été
bouleversée parce que j'ai jamais vu ça
nulle part alors michel foucault
maintenant votre regard de philosophe
sur ce pays de vaud est ce qu'il s'agit
d'un pays normalisé maintenant franck en
effet il faut s'arrêter sur ce mot de
normalisation qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
employer officiellement par le
gouvernement polonais mais enfin je
crois que ça en dedans grands processus
de normalisation il faut tout de même
savoir que être normalisées là-bas
normalisation lama ça veut dire
interdiction des syndicats interdiction
du droit de grève
on a pu lire dans les journaux hier soir
le détail extraordinaire de cette loi
qui est censée organiser les syndicats
mais en fait tout à l'heure que vous
rappeliez tout à l'heure les anglais et
dans cette loi il est vraisemblable
qu'il sera explicitement précisé que le
mot même de solidarité ne devra plus
être employé pour désigner un mouvement
syndical quelconque
eh bien il faut se dire que c'est cela
le régime normal d'un pays socialiste de
l'est
et c'est pourtant un pays européen c'est
à dire ce que je voudrais dire au
cerveau de la normalisation c'est que si
la normalisation est un processus
gouvernemental
si on peut dire qu'un pays comme la
tchécoslovaquie et normalisé peut-être
la pologne sera bientôt ça ne veut pas
dire du tout que la population est
normalisée est sous cette normalisation
se passe encore toute une série de
mouvements de processus de protestation
diverses d'action comme scène des
acteurs vont parler simone signoret il
ya encore sur les pavés de varsovie
décroître fleurs avec des vieilles
femmes et des jeunes gens qui chantent
qui font le signe de la victoire
non c'est la raison non cela reste une
exception dans la normalisation à la
socialiste qui règne
alors je crois en effet que le problème
de la pologne un problème très important
et il me semble que s'il est tout à fait
nécessaire d'aller le plus souvent
possible en pologne la pologne n'est pas
fermée on peut y aller je crois qu'il
faut aussi y aller et parler avec les
polonais et il ne demande qu'une chose
c'est à pouvoir discuter dans le mesure
où ils peuvent encore le faire
en revanche nous je crois qu'en europe
et en france en particulier nous devons
poser le problème de l'apologue du fait
qu'il y a à notre frontière un pays il y
as partageant l'europe
une ligne qui délimite et park une série
de pays dans lesquels ces libertés
absolument fondamental n'existe pas et
il nous semble que le problème de
l'europe n'a jamais été suffisamment
poser dans ces termes j'ai beaucoup
interrogé sur l'europe du charpentier
on s'est beaucoup interrogé sur l'europe
dans sa du rideau de fer
mais le fait que l'europe sont ainsi
partagé n'est pas encore semble-t-il
suffisamment entré dans le champ des
questions politiques
c'est un problème politique urgent et
alors justement 20 nano comment nous
voit-il les polonais comment voit-il
date ipd des rosettes et j'ai vécu plus
d'un en pologne il ya vingt ans et je me
souviens très bien que on évoquait
souvent cette espèce de grand
contentieux historique qui fait que la
pologne qui doit jusqu'à un certain
point son existence à certains traités
internationaux comme le traité de
versailles doit aussi sa disparition à
l'abandon des pays occidentaux et les
polonais nous en ont souvent gardé une
certaine rancune
en tout cas je sais que maintenant les
polonais certains pour l'année en tout
cas refuse d'avoir avec les autorités
françaises en pologne ambassades
institutions culturelles etc
des rapports quelconque à cause de ce
qui s'est passé en france d'un certain
nombre de choix politiques et en
particulier
de la continuation en dépit de la
situation polonaise des accords
tractations économiques et diplomatiques
comme par exemple le traité concerne un
gazoduc et à cause de cela ils ne
veulent plus avoir de rapport et les
français je crois que c'est très grave
et je crois que nous devons de savoir et
je crois que notre devoir de citoyen et
bien de ceux plus posé publiquement et
au gouvernement la question de la
pologne et de tous les pays socialistes
ainsi normalisée merci michel foucault
merci simone signoret